pourtant les vrais sujets ne manquent
pas inflation précarité service public
fragilisés la France est au bord de
l'implosion sociale et vous regardez
ailleurs vous mettez en place une
réforme des retraites qui pèse sur le
dos des salariés sans appeler à la
solidarité des plus riches mais là-haut
à l'Élysée on écoute pas on n'entend pas
les français et je me fais les codes de
l'intersyndical et je répète ces mots le
silence du président de la République
constitue un grave problème démocratique
qui conduit à une situation qui pourrait
devenir explosive alors madame n'a pas
un ministre pouvez-vous demander au
président d'entendre les Français
pouvez-vous lui demander de recevoir
l'Inter syndicale comme elle le demande
pouvez-vous lui demander de retirer
cette réforme
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Patrick Kanner
comme toutes les précédentes la réforme
que nous portons pour les retraites
suscite certaines oppositions qui
s'expriment notamment dans la rue c'est
le droit des syndicats et de nos
concitoyens se doit ce droit bien
évidemment je le respecte et je respecte
les Français et les syndicats qui font
entendre leur position dans le respect
de nos lois hier une journée de
mobilisation s'est tenue avec
sensiblement le même nombre de
manifestants que fin janvier et dans la
plupart des cas sont débordement
[Musique]
alors je veux saluer les forces de
l'ordre mobilisés pour veiller à la
sécurité de cette journée d'action je
veux aussi saluer la responsabilité des
manifestants je regrette bien sûr que
des incidents étaient émaillés certains
cortèges par exemple à Paris ou à
Marseille je condamne les coupures
d'électricité dans certains tribunaux
dans certaines universités dans certains
quartiers et dans certaines permanences
parlementaires le droit de grève ça
n'est pas le droit au blocage ou la
volonté de mettre notre économie à
genoux hier soir l'interf syndical a
demandé à être reçu le gouvernement est
toujours prêt et ouvert au dialogue
comme il l'a montré ces derniers mois si
les organisations syndicales souhaitent
évoquer certains points particuliers la
porte du ministre du Travail Olivier du
soft reste toujours ouverte
car je le rappelle c'est bien dans la
concertation et le dialogue que ce texte
a été construit c'est après trois mois
de concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales et les groupes
parlementaires que nous avons décidé de
décaler progressivement l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans et non pas
65 ans comme prévu initialement je
rappelle aussi je rappelle aussi que
c'est grâce au dialogue que nous avons
décidé de revaloriser les plus petits
pensions des retraités actuels et je
vous rappelle encore que c'est grâce au
dialogue que nous avons amélioré le
texte sur la pénibilité mais ces sujets
ne vous sont peut-être pas importants
monsieur sénateur mais je crois que
c'est important la pénibilité les
transitions au poivre retraite la prise
en compte des trimestres de travaux
d'utilité collective les fameux tubes
des années 80 ce sont des changements
significatifs nous sommes prêts à
d'autres j'ai pas par exemple eu
l'occasion de dire que j'étais ouverte à
une surcote pour celles qui auront la
durée de cotisation à 63 ans toutes ces
questions sont
au coeur au Parlement vous en discutez
actuellement au sein même de cette
émission et je le répète nous sommes
prêts à faire évoluer à améliorer et
enrichir ce texte dans le respect de ses
équilibres mais pour y parvenir nous
devons pouvoir débattre loyalement
ouvertement et franchement et je peine à
comprendre monsieur le Président Kanner
votre ton vous insinuations et vos
attaques comme vous le savez le
gouvernement n'intervient pas dans
l'organisation des débats au Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
temps de la concertation a eu lieu le
débat au Parlement doit se tenir dans le
respect des uns et des autres sans
blocage avec une volonté de discussion
sincère c'est le fondement de notre
démocratie nous ne pouvons pas et nous
ne devons pas opposer la légitimité de
la rue à celle de nos institutions
depuis quelques jours et jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine la discussion va se
poursuivre au Sénat plus de senteurs de
débats sont prévus au total vous avez
les cartes en main pour agir
cartes en main pour enrichir le texte
les cartes en main pour donner à tous
les Français le débat démocratique qui
réclame je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président Kader
notre premier ministre vous n'étiez pas
dans l'hémicycle cette nuit vous auriez
peut-être eu un discours différent mais
finalement quand j'ai employé le mode
d'entêtement je me suis trompé
c'est de l'aveuglement vis-à-vis de
notre pays et finalement je ne vais pas
vous répliquer madame l'après ministre
je vais parler aux Français les Français
pourront compter sur nous sur notre
détermination pour faire face à cette
mauvaise réforme indigne par rapport à
leurs intérêts et je vous le dis très
simplement ils peuvent compter sur nous
au Sénat pour être leur porte-voix
merci la parole d'état de notre collègue
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la presse a beaucoup commenté
les conclusions du rapport du chef de la
maternité de l'hôpital Necker sur
l'avenir des petites maternités il a été
adopté à une large majorité par
l'Académie de médecine pas plus tard
qu'hier et préconise la fin des
accouchements dans une plus d'une
centaine de maternité de niveau 1 qui
pratique moins de 1000 accouchements à
l'année ce rapport pose l'ambition de
renforcer la sécurité des parturientes
face aux difficultés rencontrées par ces
maternités manque de personnels recours
trop fréquents à l'intérim perte
d'attractivité
l'objectif nous le partageons tous et
bien sûr qu'une maternité qui n'est plus
en capacité d'assurer la sécurité des
mamans et des bébés doit suspendre son
activité d'accouchement mais pour autant
pour autant érigé en dogme la question
du nombre de naissances pour justifier
la fermeture du net d'une maternité
serait niée les disparités territoriales
la fermeture d'une salle de naissance
proche d'une zone urbaine n'aura pas les
mêmes conséquences pour les femmes qu'en
zone rurale ou de montagne ou l'accès
aux réseaux routier les moyens de
transport revient plus difficile une
étude menée en 2013 en Bourgogne a
montré l'impact négatif de la santé
périnatale sur des temps d'accès
supérieurs à 45 minutes ce rapport elle
mérite de poser le problème et les
réponses ne peuvent être basées sur des
simples calculs mathématiques elles
doivent prendre en compte les
particularités de chaque territoire et
fonctionnement de chaque établissement
pour vous donner un exemple en Lorraine
sur 19 maternités nous en avons 10 de
type 1 et 14 qui pratiquent des moins de
1000 accouchements à l'année vous
comprenez donc que ce rapport soulève à
la fois des questions et des inquiétudes
aussi madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous dire si vous comptez appuyer vous
comptez vous appuyez sur ce rapport pour
un futur plan national de périnatalité
ce rapport est-il une commande ou une
initiative spontanée enfin qu'elle sera
la ligne choisie par le gouvernement
pour assurer un suivi de grossesse et un
accouchement en toute sécurité pour
toutes les femmes de notre pays pour
vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée
on cherche de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
madame fermez-le boudo merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur madame la sénatrice
Guillotin tout d'abord je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence du ministre François
Brown vous évoquez le rapport sur la
planification de la périnatalité rendue
par l'Académie de médecine avec mon
collègue François Brune nous avons pris
connaissance des analyses et
propositions de ce rapport je le
rappelle la canne diminue de médecine
est une structure indépendante il s'agit
d'un avis scientifique qui n'engage en
rien le gouvernement je veux être très
clair la remise de ce rapport ne
signifie aucunement comme certains
s'amusent à le laisser entendre fermer
massivement des maternités ou remettre
du jour en cause du jour au lendemain 30
ans de politique périnatale dans notre
pays la question que pose ce rapport est
importante et renvoie à l'équilibre
nécessaire entre proximité et sécurité
des actes je le redis la sécurité n'est
pas négociable la volonté qui est la
nôtre c'est celle de bâtir ensemble des
solutions qui permettent de garantir une
offre pour tous
toutes en assurant la qualité et la
sécurité de la prise en charge entre un
territoire périurbain et un territoire
rural les solutions à construire seront
de fait très différentes c'est tout la
philosophie de notre action et l'esprit
du CNR avec des solutions territoire par
territoire co-construite avec l'ensemble
des acteurs j'ajoute que la santé des
femmes est un enjeu essentiel sur lequel
nous allons agir et nous agissons déjà à
tous les niveaux je pense à la formation
des professionnels nous sommes
pleinement engagés dans une réflexion
globale avec l'ensemble des acteurs sur
l'évolution des filières et métiers pour
améliorer les conditions d'exercice
mieux reconnaître leurs compétences et
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers en
la matière le gouvernement agit déjà
c'est tout le sens de la loi du 25
janvier 2023 sur la formation de
sage-femme qui permettra désormais aux
sages-femmes d'obtenir le diplôme d'état
de docteur en maiotique je pense aussi
et il faut le redire aujourd'hui dans le
contexte particulier de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour accompagner et protéger la santé de
toutes les femmes au quotidien nous
voulons mieux accompagner les femmes qui
connaissent les preuves d'une fausse
couche à travers le renforcement des
dispositifs d'accompagnement
psychologique et la création de parcours
dédiés vous le savez la détermination
qui est la mienne avec François Brown
amélioré l'accès à la santé de nos
concitoyens sur tout le territoire nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés
oui merci Madame la mini je pense que
votre réponse a été claire élève au
moins l'ambigu l'ambiguïté en tout cas
les inquiétudes qui émanaient de ce
rapport comme vous je pense qu'il y a la
sécurité sur lequel nous ne devons pas
déroger mais bien évidemment que toutes
les solutions qui devront être trouvées
pour répondre en fait aux problématiques
des maternités doivent le faire
territoire par territoire et maternité
par maternité je vous remercie merci la
parole est au président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
oui merci merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes nous aurions préféré vous
interroger par la voix de Mélanie Vogel
sur les politiques que vous ne mettez
pas en œuvre en faveur de l'égalité
salariale et en faveur de la légalité
devant le départ à la retraite des
femmes et des hommes mais considérant la
mobilisation tout à fait historique oui
historique de la journée d'hier
considérant l'entrave gravissime au
débat parlementaire intervenu dans la
nuit dernière dans cette hémicycle ma
question sera donc la suivante
allez-vous retirer votre réforme de
retraite inique avant que le blocage
démocratique politique économique et
sociales du pays ne soient complet pour
vous répondre la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Guillaume Gontard tout d'abord
quand vous évoquez l'organisation
interne des débats au Sénat je voudrais
vous rappeler que je suis attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs et que le
déroulement des débats et de la
prérogative de chaque assemblée je note
toutefois que les débats avancent vous
avez voté hier la première partie du
texte et vous avez déjà pu débattre
plusieurs heures sur l'article 7 j'ai
donc toute confiance dans le Sénat pour
conduire dans les meilleures conditions
le débat mais monsieur le Président
Gontard comme vous l'avez souligné votre
question intervient le 8 mars journée
internationale du droit des femmes et
donc je voudrais profiter de ce moment
pour vous dire ma mobilisation
personnelle et celle de mon gouvernement
pour l'égalité réelle entre les femmes
et les hommes
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la grande cause des deux quinquennats
d'Emmanuel Macron je me bats pour
l'égalité et pour les droits des femmes
depuis des années alors j'ai veillé
est-ce que ce projet pour nos retraites
tienne compte au mieux des carrières des
femmes et œuvre à réduire les inégalités
notre projet protège celles qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt en améliorant
le dispositif carrière longue et en y
intégrant les congés parentaux notre
projet protège celles qui ont des
carrières incomplètes en permettant la
validation des trimestres de congés
parentaux où les périodes d'aidant qui
sont souvent des femmes et on ne
modifiant pas l'âge d'annulation de la
décote qui concerne une femme sur 5
notre projet protège celles et ceux qui
ont des revenus modestes tout au long de
leur vie professionnelle ce sont à la
fois les retraités futurs et les
retraités actuels qui bénéficieront
d'une revalorisation de la pension
minimale pour les deux tiers ce sont des
femmes ainsi dans les prochaines années
l'écart de pension entre les femmes et
les hommes va se réduire d'un tiers
comme depuis le début nous restons
attentifs aux propositions constructives
et nous sommes ouverts à des évolutions
du texte notamment pour réduire les
inégalités de pension entre les femmes
et des hommes cela peut passer par une
surcote de toutes celles qui auront la
durée nécessaire de cotisation à 63 ans
vous aurez l'occasion d'en débattre tout
à l'heure mais la retraite ne peut pas à
elle seule corriger toutes les
inégalités d'une vie professionnelle
c'est pourquoi nous devons également
continuer à nous battre pour l'égalité
tout au long de la vie professionnelle
je vous remercie tu es le président
d'auteur
madame la Première ministre votre
discours faussement pédagogique encore
plus sur l'égalité aux femmes ne
convaincent personne de quoi que ce soit
si ce n'est de rejoindre les cortèges
des manifestations vous portez la
responsabilité de cette réforme dont
personne ne veut vous portez la
responsabilité du blocage du pays vous
portez la responsabilité d'un choix
constitutionnel le 47,1 qui musait le
Parlement vous portez avec vos alliés de
droite la responsabilité du délit
démocratique à l'oeuvre vous portez
demain la responsabilité de l'arrivée de
l'extrême droite au pouvoir madame la
Premier ministre vous avez déjà trahi
maintes fois les promesses formulées
devant le Parlement en juillet dernier
cessez de mentir aux françaises et aux
Français cessez de dissimuler vos
négociations d'antichambre avec les
lambeaux de la droite cessez de vous
faire dicter votre action politique ou
bien alors remanier le gouvernement
intégrer et l'air à votre coalition
et revenez devant le Parlement nous
présenter avec sincérité le projet de
cas social et de régression sociétale le
projet de droite qui est le vôtre en
attendant nous vous demandons
solennellement au nom de l'immense
majorité du peuple français et de
l'insert syndical de retirer ce projet
inutile car comme la si bien dit le
porte-parole du gouvernement le pays a
d'autres urgences à gérer
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Franck melonville pour le gros plaisir
indépendants République et territoire
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'interdiction de
la vente de voiture neuve à moteur
thermique en 2035 a été validé par le
Parlement européen le 14 février dernier
le vote par les États membres pour
l'entériner devait avoir lieu hier
heureusement il a été reporté cinédier
en raison de l'abstention de l'Allemagne
dorénavant plusieurs pays s'opposent au
toute électrique mettant en avant leur
doute quant à l'incidence sur cette
évolution technique et technologique sur
l'industrie c'est interdiction n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune étude d'impact
préalable les conséquences pourraient
être très lourdes disparition de
centaines de milliers d'emplois en
Europe des industrialisations
historiques au profit de la Chine ou
d'autres pays peu respectueux de
l'environnement
perte de capacité d'innovation notamment
en matière de carburant propre de plus
il faut tenir compte de leur utilisation
qui n'est absolument pas adaptée dans
nos territoires ruraux en matière
d'autonomie de batterie de distance un
parcourir et de matériel de recharge
sur un cycle de vie du produit Le
emprunte écologique n'est pas neutre on
ne peut pas on sait que la production
donc des batteries et le recyclage
soulève de nombreux problèmes de
nombreuses difficultés et accentue notre
dépendance Renaud par la voix de son
président jodominique Sénard pense qu'en
2050 grâce à la recherche et le
développement le moteur thermique
pourrait disposer du même bilan carbone
que l'électrique loin de moi l'idée
d'opposer thermique électrique mais je
venais néanmoins rappeler que nous
sommes un des leaders des petits moteurs
diesel que nous disposons encore de
grandes capacités d'évolution et
d'innovation ne nous enfermons donc pas
dans le tout électrique en excluant le
thermique mais plutôt mobisons-nous pour
une mobilité toujours plus propre
monsieur le ministre quelle est la
position de la France sur ce dossier
nous devons protéger notre industrie
automobile nos compétences garantir nos
intérêts et se fermer aucune
de développement et d'innovation la
parole pour vous répondez communistes de
la transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mais Nonville
l'Union européenne le 29 juin dernier a
par le biais d'un accord entre États
membres validé cette réglementation ça a
fait l'objet d'un vote de 14 février et
depuis quelques jours pour des raisons
politiques internes à sa coalition
l'Allemagne menace de ne pas tenir sa
parole ce serait à la fois un très
mauvais signal pour nos engagements
climatiques et un danger pour notre
industrie si les choses devaient en
rester là
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des véhicules thermiques c'est à eux
seuls plus que toutes les émissions
agricoles à eux seuls plus que toutes
les émissions industrielles à eux seuls
plus que toutes les émissions qui sont
liées au bâtiment
les biocarburants c'est une impasse on
n'a pas la surface pour compenser les
hydrocarbures et on en aura besoin pour
le maritime et l'aérien et c'est vrai
pour le if Youle pour les carburants de
synthèse qu'on doit utiliser pour les
moteurs qui ne pourront pas été
électrifiés en particulier l'aérien et
maritime si on veut viser la neutralité
carbone 2035 en l'état ça veut pas dire
la fin des moteurs thermiques ça veut
dire la fin de vente des moteurs neufs
avec évidemment pour le diesel pour
l'hybride des véhicules qui continueront
à circuler mais monsieur le sénateur et
je sais que votre intérêt pour
l'industrie de notre pays est réel avec
Clément Bones avec Bruno Le Maire notre
obsession c'est précisément qu'il y a un
cap clair qui soit donné aux industriels
depuis quelques jours Valeo Volkswagen
stelantis Renault insiste sur la
nécessité de pas envoyer de
contresignales au moment où ces
constructeurs et ses équipementsiers
investissent des milliards d'euros comme
avec le pôle électricité dans les hauts
de France pour se préparer à être prêt
ne pas le faire ce serait continué à se
faire tailler des croupières par
l'industrie chinoise qui effectivement
fabrique des véhicules électriques avec
des usines à charbon se préparer à ça et
assumer un changement pour faire en
sorte de l'accompagner c'est à la fois
la voix qui est souhaitable pour le
climat pour l'industrie et pour nos
emplois
la parole est à notre collègue
Jacqueline Eustache Brignoud pour le
groupe les républicains
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre femme vie liberté en ce 8 mars
comment ne pas penser avec le cœur lourd
à toutes les femmes victimes
d'oppression dans le monde et plus
particulièrement aux iraniennes et aux
Afghans courageusement elle se battent
chaque jour au péril de notre vie pour
dénoncer des régimes qui ni leur
existence qui veulent les rendre
invisibles et qui les empêchent
d'accéder à la culture à l'école au
savoir et donc à leur émancipation alors
jusqu'à empoisonner des centaines
d'écolières en Iran leur force et leur
courage nous obligent à l'action à
l'image de ce qu'était la partie raciale
en Afrique du Sud ces femmes sont
victimes d'un véritable apartheid sexuel
en 1973 les Nations Unies adoptaient le
texte de la convention internationale
sur l'élimination et la répression du
crime d'apartheid qui a permis de
prendre des mesures sur le plan
international en vue d'éliminer de
réprimer le crime d'appartheid en ce 50e
anniversaire de cette convention la
France sonorerait en portant une
initiative auprès des Nations Unies et
tendance cette convention à l'aparthèse
sexuelle en proposant d'inclure ce type
de discrimination à l'article 2
définissant le terme d'apartheid cette
proposition initiée par la Ligue du
droit international des femmes et
soutenu par de nombreux juristes et
intellectuels parmi lesquels sherine et
Badi iranienne prix Nobel de la paix
alors la France pays des droits de
l'homme pays des Lettres persanes
aura-t-elle l'ambition et le courage de
porter cette demande on assure Unies en
y associant ses partenaires européens
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à on a
mis la belle Rome ministre délégué
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes chargés de la diversité
l'égalité des chances
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice oui bien sûr aujourd'hui nous
pensons à toutes ces femmes qui sont
opprimées un peu partout dans le monde
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes la France est l'un des
rares pays d'ailleurs à cette dotée
d'une diplomatie féministe portée avec
conviction par Catherine Colonna elle
s'est elle a été lancée notamment lors
du Forum génération égalité en 2021 au
cours duquel ce sont plus de 40
milliards d'euros qui ont été
attribués justement à l'égalité femme
homme un peu partout dans le monde avec
Catherine Colonna une de nos priorités
et d'universaliser la convention
d'Istanbul qui est un des textes
fondateurs des droits des femmes
puisqu'il reconnaît cette violence
structurelle des sociétés à l'égard des
femmes et qu'ils demandent au pays
ratificateur d'agir de des mesures en
termes d'éducation de prévention de
sanctions justement pour protéger les
femmes et les enfants et nous avons
vraiment cette ambition de porter haut
et fort cette convention internationale
par ailleurs nous avons lancé aussi en
2019 un fondation national de soutien
aux organisations féministes dans le
monde j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
de leurs représentante et toutes sont
très satisfaites justement de cette aide
à porter j'ajouterai que la France qui
est ce pays de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen est aussi le
pays des Droits des Femmes et peut-être
que lorsque elle inscrira dans son texte
le plus élevé c'est à dire la
Constitution le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse peut-être
sera-t-elle aussi un phare pour toutes
les femmes du monde et un signe d'espoir
que nous leur enverrons voilà donc nous
pensons bien sûr à toutes ces femmes et
notre mobilisation est totale pour les
droits des femmes et nous dans le monde
entier voilà je vous remercie madame
brignot madame la ministre j'attendais
un oui ou un nom à ma question rien
d'autre rien d'autre
c'est par notre inaction parce que tout
ça est l'inaction régnait un thème
climatereur en verset femme envers ces
jeunes filles à travers le monde les
courageuses iraniennes et afghan et
toutes les femmes opprimées combattant
de la liberté moderne de résistance nous
donne une son elles ont besoin de
preuves tangibles de notre soutien ne
les décevons pas ne brisons pas leurs
rêves
ma parole est à la présidente de l'Union
européens
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues en cette journée symbolique du
8 mars journée internationale des droits
de la femme ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre en charge de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avant-hier un homme a été placé en garde
à vue à Poitiers il est suspecté d'avoir
des fenestré sa femme deux jours avant
c'était en Gironde qu'un homme
poignardait sa femme depuis le 1er
janvier 26 femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex-conjoint pourtant le
Président de la République a déclaré
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
grandes causes nationales depuis 2017
pourtant un Grenelle sur les violences
conjugales cette tenue en 2019 pourtant
le budget consacré à l'égalité à
sensiblement progresser pourtant le
Parlement a adopté pas moins de quatre
textes de loi mais les chiffres sont là
130 femmes en 2017 106 en 2022 les
personnels restent insuffisamment formés
des drames aurait pu être évités si les
procédures prévues dans la loi avaient
été respectée une plainte pour violence
conjugale doit être immédiatement
transmise au procureur madame la
ministre vous avez récemment présenté le
dispositif qui doit permettre d'aider
les femmes qui sont en situation de
danger à s'extraire des griffes de leur
conjoint violents avant qu'ils ne soient
trop tard permettez-moi de regretter le
manque d'ambition du calendrier de ce
pack nouveau départ un premier test de
trois mois doit être mené dans le
Val-d'Oise avant d'être étendu dans
quatre autres territoires dont seulement
un rural et un ultramarin la
généralisation du pack au niveau
national n'est envisagé que d'ici 2025
ou 2026 si le gouvernement est convaincu
de ce dispositif pourquoi attendre aussi
longtemps avant de le généraliser
pourquoi ne pas accélérer le déploiement
du pack pourquoi risquer la vie de moi
300 femmes
faut vous répondre la parole est à
madame Isabelle
[Musique]
et les hommes
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la sénatrice Annick Bellon tout d'abord
permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée
effectivement pour toutes ces victimes
les féminicides c'est beaucoup trop et
depuis 2017 beaucoup a été fait
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé que ce
soit en termes de protection des
victimes en termes d'outils de
protection le déploiement massif des
téléphones graves dangers on en a plus
de 3000 aujourd'hui le bracelet anti
rapprochement nous avons
considérablement aussi augmenter les
places d'hébergement d'urgence plus 80%
formé massivement les policiers les
gendarmes en a 150000 formés donc bien
sûr que nous avons avancé nous allons
aller encore plus loin et effectivement
la première ministre a annoncé dès début
septembre le lancement de ce nouveau
dispositif ce pack nouveau départ pour
aider les victimes à quitter leur
conjoint c'est-à-dire assez extraire des
griffes de ce bourreau parce que c'est
difficile de partir quand on a été
pendant des années humilier dévalorisés
harceler et donc justement l'objectif de
ce pack c'est de pouvoir déclencher pour
elle à certains nombres d'aides
matériels dont elles ont besoin une
allocation ça peut être une allocation
une aide au retour à l'emploi ou à la
formation une aide pour la garde des
enfants un accompagnement psychologique
et si besoin un hébergement d'urgence
l'intérêt de ce dispositif c'est que il
peut être déclenché par tout signalant
c'est-à-dire que ça peut être un
travailleur social un médecin un avocat
un soignant une association qui va
saisir un référent unique à la caisse
d'allocations familiales ou à la CMSA
dans les zones rurales et qui va ensuite
déclencher de manière prioritaire toutes
ces aides
12 semaines d'expérimentation pour le
premier territoire dans le Val-d'Oise et
ensuite il y aura comme vous l'avez dit
4 autres territoires et un an au total
d'expérimentation il faut il ne faut pas
fabriquer une usine à gaz mais permettre
de répondre le mieux possible aux
besoins des victimes c'est pour ça qu'il
faut un peu de temps merci
la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en affirmant que les
femmes seront les grandes gagnantes de
la réforme des retraites le gouvernement
instrumentalisent la cause des femmes en
réalité c'est une réforme contre les
femmes elle ne corrigeant rien les
inégalités salariales de 28 % les
inégalités de pension de 40 % et elle
monte après votre étude d'impact que les
femmes devront repousser l'âge auquel
elles prennent leur retraite bien plus
tard encore que les hommes vous le
saviez et vous le saviez et vous le
savez donc depuis le début mais ça nous
empêche pas de continuer à tenter de
nous vendre le contraire il faut dire
que la majorité sénatoriale vous êtes
bien quelle triste et scandaleux
spectacle de Neyer avec l'utilisation de
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui a
bayonné l'opposition avec les avec
l'accord des droites Unis républicain
centriste et macroniste votre réponse
votre réforme est bien une réforme de
droite monsieur du soft alors ma
question est simple en ce 8 mars 2023
journée internationale de lutte pour les
droits des femmes allez-vous enfin
sortir du déni et renoncer à votre
réforme qui a mis encore hier des
millions de femmes et d'hommes dans la
rue pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail Monsieur Olivier du
chope merci beaucoup madame monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Laurence
Cohen vous l'avez dit nous sommes le 8
mars j'en ai international des droits
des femmes et vous avez interrogé le
gouvernement sur le contenu de la
réforme des retraites pour ce qui
concerne les femmes nous l'avons voulu
nous l'avons fait madame la Première
ministre l'a dit à tout à l'heure la
réforme que nous portons apporte un
certain nombre d'améliorations des
améliorations de plusieurs ordres
d'abord vous savez et nous savons tous
que la manière dont nous avons envisagé
de revaloriser les plus petites pensions
sera plus bénéfique aux femmes qu'aux
hommes pourquoi est-ce que ça sera plus
bénéfique aux femmes causes hommes parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement mais j'y
reviendrai les femmes sont celles qui
ont les plus petites retraite dans notre
pays de la même manière nous intégrons
dans les trimestres retenus pour
calculer l'éligibilité que ce soit au
départ anticipé dans le cadre des
carrières longues que ce soit pour les
gibbilité au minimum de pension un
certain nombre de trimestres cotisés au
titre de l'assurance vieillesse pour les
parents au foyer de la même manière nous
sommes ouverts un certain nombre
d'amendements des amendements qui n'ont
pas pu être examinés à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont déposés ici et qui
vont permettre de prendre en compte les
indemnités journalières verset en 2012
pour relever le niveau de retraite des
femmes qui vont permettre aussi
d'améliorer la situation des femmes et
des parents au sens plus large sur des
sujets parfois très sensibles je pense
notamment aux devenir du calcul des
pensions de retraite en cas de perte
d'un enfant pour les familles qui ont
plus de trois enfants votre assemblée
est saisi d'un certain nombre de
propositions notamment des propositions
portées par le président retaille aux
permettant de surcoter les trimestres
acquis par les femmes une fois qu'elles
ont atteint la du crise et avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits et je peux vous
assurer que cette proposition a un
équilibre qu'il faut regarder et qu'il
faut regarder avec je crois le plus
d'ouverture d'esprit possible et enfin
Madame la présidente Madame la ténatrice
pardonnez-moi c'est pas la première fois
que je vous qualifie ainsi vous avez
rappelé que nous sommes le 8 mars et
peut-être puisque vous avez gardé un
certain temps pour me répondre peut-être
que nous pourrons convenir ensemble en
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes que la vraie inégalité de
pension elle ne n’est pas de notre
système de retraite elle n'est des
inégalités professionnelles et que c'est
sur le chantier de l'égalité
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
que nous devons porter tous nos efforts
pour que les pensions soient les mêmes
entre les femmes et les hommes
[Applaudissements]
un homme
avec vous monsieur le ministre le 8 mars
et la journée du recul des droits des
femmes ce que vous nous avez dit ce sont
des contre-vérités la seule chose avec
laquelle je suis d'accord c'est qu'il
faudrait effectivement une grande loi
travail et l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes c'est bête fin aux inégalités
salariales revaloriser les métiers
féminis et notamment les
aides-soignantes les auxiliaires de vie
tous les métiers du soin et du lien
ainsi que les personnels de propreté qui
ont manifesté ce matin devant le Sénat
faire cotiser à temps plein les emplois
à temps partiel
augmenter le taux d'emploi des femmes
autant d'argent pour les caisses de
sécurité sociale ça permettrait de
renflouer votre soi-disant déficit juste
qui justifie votre projet régressif
voilà une réforme de justice et
d'égalité pour les femmes une réforme
féministe en ce 8 mars les femmes sont
dans la rue pour le crier le peuple est
encore dans la rue que ça vous plaise ou
que ça ne vous plaise pas et ils vont
toutes et tous dire non aux deux genres
de vie que vous voulez leur voler
parole est à notre collègue n'a déjà vu
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
[Applaudissements]
dans l'agenda politique international
n'est pas à la mesure de leur rôle dans
les équilibres planétaires il y a un an
à Brest c'est le constat que dressait le
président de la République en conclusion
du premier Sommet mondial qui leur était
dédié un rassemblement inédit des
dirigeants mondiaux organisés dans le
cadre de la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne avec cette
volonté d'accélérer à cette occasion
avait été lancé une coalition de près de
50 états réaffirmant leur objectif
parvenir enfin après des années de
négociation à un texte contraignant sur
la gouvernance de la haute mer pour
mieux la protéger c'est désormais chose
faite après celui de décembre un
deuxième accord de la plus haute
importance a été conclue ce 4 mars à New
York sous l'égide de l'ONU il vient
acter le futur traité international sur
l'île d'utilisation durable de la
conservation de la université en haute
mer les mesures qui figurent ont été
jugées essentielles pour nos écosystèmes
avec notamment la création désormais
entérinée d'air marine protégée et je
profite de cette prise de parole pour
saluer une nouvelle fois ici les travaux
menés par nos collègues tevaro fridge et
Michel Canevet sur les fonds marins
notre groupe tient à saluer cette
avancée majeure dans la protection de
nos océans puis de carbone essentiel à
la régulation climatique et à la lutte
contre le réchauffement nous saluons le
rôle actif joué par la France dans cette
recherche d'un accord mondial monsieur
le secrétaire d'État pourriez-vous
détailler les avancées portées par ce
traité essentiel et les actions qu'il
reste amener pour la mise en oeuvre
concrète de cette instrument
international juridiquement contraignant
je vous remercie la parole est au
secrétaire d'État en charge de la mère
monsieur rdberville monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la c'est un triste avait d'abord
je me permets de vous remercier pour
engagement pour la préservation des
océans celle de votre groupe et celle
également du sénateur Teva roadschritz
vous l'avez dit dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche les États membres des Nations
Unies ont conclu un accord sur la
protection de la biodiversité marine en
haute mer qui est un espace qui est
situé à 370 km des côtes ce n'est pas le
fruit du hasard il y a plus d'un an le
président de la République est l'Union
européenne ont relancé ce texte qui
était enlisé depuis 15 ans c'est un
tournant majeur pour la protection des
océans puisque c'est un traité qui est
juridiquement contraignant et qui
préserve un espace qui recouvre 45% de
la surface de la planète alors ce traité
est décisif pour au moins trois raisons
la première c'est qu'il oblige les États
à avoir des études d'impact
environnemental pour toute nouvelle
activité en haute mer la deuxième raison
c'est qu'il ouvre la voie à la création
très concrète d'air marine protégée en
haute mer et puis la troisième qui est
une raison et qui montre à quel point
c'est un traité historique c'est que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des négociations environnementales les
décisions ne seront plus prises
en Suisse qui permettait à des Data de
bloquer mais à la majorité ce qui
permettra d'établir partout des aires
marines protégées à la majorité et donc
ne pas dans notre processus de blocage
quels sont les prochaines étapes la
première c'est l'entrée en vigueur il
faudra que 60 états leur ratifient pour
qu'il entre en vigueur et notre objectif
c'est que d'ici le sommet des Nations
Unies pour les océans qui se tiendra en
France en 2025 à Nice nous puissions
avoir une entrée en vigueur le deuxième
c'est de poursuivre le combat sur la
protection des océans et donc la France
continuera à mobiliser pour notamment
l'interdiction de l'exploitation minière
des grands fonds marins qui a un combat
essentiel et donc vous voyez nous ne
pourrons pas gagner le course contre la
montre climatique si nous protégeons pas
les océans si nous présentons pas la
haute mer et c'est tout l'intérêt de se
traiter qui a été
à conclu par les États membres des
Nations Unies je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Alain
jouant des pour le groupe les
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre la France
libératrice du Mali est chassé d'Afrique
quasiment sans préavis
Centre Afrique Burkina Faso etc
la France est grande puissance
diplomatique qui a normalement
l'engage
universel qui doit parler à tout le
monde cette France se fâche avec ses
partenaires la même réussie à se fâcher
en même temps il faut le faire avec le
Maroc et l'Algérie
on est donc face à un échec diplomatique
cuisant dramatique pour l'avenir
j'allais vous demander quel est votre
politique pour l'Afrique mais le
président de la République a déclaré le
27 février qui avait plus de politique
française en Afrique alors est-ce vrai
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Madame Catherine Colonna
madame la ministre merci Monsieur
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je
connais votre intérêt pour l'Afrique
mais voyez-vous depuis quelques temps en
Afrique a changé et la France aussi a
changé l'Afrique a changé elle est
depuis un certain temps mais je suis sûr
que l'ancien ministre s'en est souvenu
l'Afrique est pour les décennies qui
viennent une terre de croissance une
terre d'opportunité une terre de
création le présent de la République a
pu le constater par exemple lors de son
déplacement la semaine dernière auprès
des entrepreneurs et des artistes réunis
à l'Institut français de Kinshasa et
l'Afrique a changé aussi monsieur
sénateur parce que elle n'entend pas se
faire dicter par l'extérieur ce qui est
bon pour elle les pays africains
défendent leurs intérêts avec raison et
nous le faisons tous mais la France
aussi a changé et nous voulons sortir
des visions datées l'Afrique les pays
africains car il y a plusieurs Afrique
vous le savez bien ne sont spectateur
d'une concurrence entre puissance nous
avons sur ce continent des partenaires
des défis communs et des atouts à
utiliser nos liens humains nos diasporas
nous entrepreneurs nos universités ne
résout culturels et le dynamisme de nos
genèse et la France a changé aussi parce
qu'elle met en place des outils pour
développer ces nouveaux partenariats
alors nous savons aussi qu'il nous faut
lutter davantage contre la
désinformation contre les manipulations
de l'information et nous savons aussi
quels sont les forces qui sont à
l'oeuvre pour avancer dans une stratégie
qui certainement ne fera pas avancer ni
la paix ni la stabilité ni la prospérité
des pays considérés et c'est en
additionnant toutes ces actions que nous
resterons un partenaire actif sur ce
continent dans notre intérêt dans celui
de nos peuples et dans l'intérêt de
l'Europe également
monsieur joyeux
oui merci madame la ministre je crois
surtout que si les choses ont changé la
France doit reprendre son destin en main
en Afrique comme ailleurs nous refusons
d'ailleurs suite à la déclaration
franco-américaine de mois de novembre
2022 une éventuelle un éventuel
copilotage de nos bases en Afrique avec
nos alliés des États-Unis d'Amérique la
France suffisamment grande pour
s'occuper d'une vraie politique en
Afrique vous avez des moyens à votre
disposition madame la ministre vous
savez que nous disposons quand même de
ces bases prépositionnées en Afrique les
accords ont été renégociés en 2010 ils
sont très vivants ils sont utiles c'est
pas la peine de vouloir tout casser les
déclarations que nous avons entendues
sont particulièrement inquiétantes vous
avez un corps diplomatique qu'il
faudrait protéger au lieu de le casser
qui est exceptionnel et avec lequel
et avec lequel nous avons défini nous
avons défini une ligne très claire pour
l'Afrique très intelligente ni ingérence
ni des daim nous ne les laissons pas
tomber mais en même temps nous ne sommes
pas effectivement des colonialistes nous
devons combattre cette idée le président
de la République ne doit pas laisser
dire que la France est un État
néocolonialiste c'est vraiment l'honneur
de la France et notre image nous ne
devons plus être humiliés sur tous ces
sujets
je conclus surtout ces sujets madame la
ministre le Sénat la commission des
affaires étrangères peut vous aider avec
le président avec le président Cambon
nous vous demandons ici un débat
parlementaire merci
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
me protège qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt les femmes qui sont dans les métiers
difficiles les femmes qui ont dû
interrompre leur carrière
ces propos sont de vous madame la
Première ministre et vous venez
d'ailleurs de l'héréérer aujourd'hui
j'ai une pensée pour les femmes que je
connais dans mon département des Landes
où l'industrie agroalimentaire est très
présente et plus particulièrement je
pense à cette femme qui avait témoignée
lors d'un important mouvement de grève
dans une entreprise de transformation
agroalimentaire de mon département et
qui avait raconté qu'elle se levait à 4h
du matin pour aller travailler dans une
sur une chaîne dévisseration de
volailles à plusieurs kilomètres de chez
elle pour un salaire à peine supérieur
au SMIC après de nombreuses années
d'ancienneté vous voyez madame la
ministre tous les critères que vous avez
cités sont réunis ici j'aimerais que
vous m'expliquiez comment ce projet de
loi va améliorer la future retraite de
cette salarié
pour me répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du top mais il
travaille du plein d'emploi de
l'insertion merci à monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice ruban si
j'ai bien écouté votre question vous
avez pris l'exemple d'une femme je
travaille dans une industrie
agroalimentaire sur une chaîne de
préparation de volaille donc un travail
physique et si j'ai bien compris aussi
un travail posté avec des départs
extrêmement tôt et vous nous dites
qu'est-ce qui est dans votre projet de
loi peuvent permettre d'aider cette
femme dans notre projet de loi ce qui va
permettre d'aider cette femme c'est
qu'au titre de la pénibilité nous allons
améliorer le compte professionnel de
prévention nous allons diminuer de 50 à
30 le nombre de travail postés qu'il
faut faire pour obtenir des points au
titre de la pénibilité si cette même
femme est exposée simultanément à la
fois des températures qui peuvent être
extrêmement basses dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire mais aussi exposer à des
aspects de manutention particulièrement
pénibles ou à des travaux de nuit elle
pourra aussi obtenir plus de points
grâce à notre projet de loi et si vous
votez cet article 9
une tranche professionnelle à laquelle
elle appartient celle de
l'agroalimentaire sera tenu obligé de
négocier un accord de prévention de la
pénibilité que nous allons cofinancer à
hauteur de 1 milliard d'euros et les
postures pénibles les vibrations le port
de charge lourdes seront prises en
charge et lui permettront à la fois de
bénéficier de prévention de formation de
reconversion mais aussi d'un suivi
médical renforcé le cas échéant si
malheureusement l'usure professionnelle
fait son œuvre la possibilité d'un
départ anticipé vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice que cette femme a travaillé
toute sa vie pour un niveau de salaire
très proche du SMIC grâce à notre projet
de loi et grâce au relèvement du minimum
contributif et donc des pensions les
plus basses nous allons pouvoir l'aider
à partir avec ton retraite meilleure que
si cette fois cette réforme n'était pas
votée et puis peut-être madame la
sénatrice que cette même femme si elle
ressemble à celle que je connais dans
mon département de l'Ardèche peut-être
qu'elle a commencé à travailler
extrêmement tôt et grâce à notre effort
mais va pouvoir partir aussi plutôt
parce que nous protégeons les carrières
longues vous sénatrices il y a un
article sur l'âge d'ouverture des droits
sur lequel nous sommes en train de
discuter et le débat reprendra tout à
l'heure mais après cet article une fois
l'obstruction que vous essayez de mettre
en place sera surmonté nous pourrons
peut-être nous intéresser à ce que dans
cette loi permettra cette femme d'être
protégée madame Lubin
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre je savais que vous
m'apporteriez une réponse parfaite
claire formatée on appuie
formater on appuie sur le bouton et tout
sort il y a pas de souci vous parlez
vous parlez des critères de pénibilité
une fois de plus je ferai remarqué que
c'est ce que vous avez enlevé nous
avions mis de véritables critères de
pénibilité vous vous êtes empressés de
l'aidant lever vous parliez des
carrières longues oui mais si cette
femme n'a pas eu la chance de commencer
à travailler juste avant 18 ans elle
travaillera quand même deux ans de plus
c'est-à-dire de 62 à 64 ans ce que ce
que je voulais dire surtout ce que je
voulais dire surtout c'est que lorsque
l'annonce a été faite de cette réforme
vous avez cherché les uns et les autres
à l'instrumentaliser la cause des femmes
pour mieux vendre votre projet de loi
mais les économistes qui se sont penchés
sur la question ont immédiante
immédiatement démonter tout cela et
enfin je terminerai comme l'exprimer ces
derniers jours madame Violaine Lucas
présidente de l'association choisir la
cause des femmes et sur un tout autre
registre celui de l'hommage
je veux moi aussi vous rappeler que les
femmes ne veulent plus ouvrir mentaliser
qu'il s'agisse des ouvrières des Landes
ou de celles qui combattent en mémoire
des plus grandes comme Gisèle Halim
i la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Sol pour
le grand plaisir
j'appelle tout le monde à respecter le
temps
[Applaudissements]
si le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues madame
la ministre alors que l'encadrement par
la loi East de la rémunération de
l'intérim médical dans le secteur public
va entrer en application à partir du 3
avril une vive inquiétude d'un peu
partout en France des ruptures
d'activité se profilent fermeture des
services d'urgence fermeture de
maternité fermeture des services de
chirurgie fragilisation de la régulation
médicale et des samues tout cela pendant
que de médecins cette décision dont je
comprends il partage la finalité va
créer dans les territoires une situation
extrêmement difficile qui va accroître
un peu plus encore l'inégalité des
Français face à l'accès aux soins
conscient des difficultés qui s'annonce
et qui inquiète est désormais de très
nombreux élus locaux vous avez demandé
aux ARS d'animés des concertations
locales territoire par territoire avec
les préfets les élus pour affiner les
diagnostics établissements par
établissement vous avez souhaité que les
ARS construisent des solutions avec les
professionnels de santé du territoire
mais également avec les centres
hospitaliers universitaires et des
établissements sièges de groupement de
territoires vous avez enfin rappelé que
les établissements privés s'étaient
engagés à suivre le gouvernement sur la
voie d'une rémunération raisonnée est
suffisant si cela ne l'est pas
envisagez-vous détendre cette régulation
pensez-vous madame la ministre que vous
instructions suffiront à répondre à la
pénurie qui se profile pouvez-vous nous
en dire plus sur le résultat du travail
que vous avez confié aux ARS car il y a
désormais urgences le Ségur de la santé
faute de s'être atelier une réforme en
profondeur de notre système de santé le
rend définitive rien régler à une
situation de plus en plus difficile
quelle est Madame la Ministre votre plan
d'action pour assurer la permanence des
soins pour redonner confiance au système
public et libéral de santé pour que le
statut des praticiens hospitaliers
salariés à l'hôpital soit attractif et
que la question de l'intérim ne se pose
plus
pauvre la parole à la ministre de
chargée de l'organisation territoriale
et des professions de santé
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs
comme vous l'avez dit je tiens à
rappeler que la régulation de l'intérim
c'est une volonté constante du
législateur et d'ailleurs cela se
traduit dans deux lois lors des deux
dernières mandatures précédentes en
effet nous assistons à certains endroits
à une dérive qui ne sont plus acceptable
et qui aurait de l'équipe même des
soignants quelques chiffres en 2021
l'intérim c'est 359 millions d'euros de
dépenses avec des rémunérations
individuelles qui pouvaient atteindre
5000 euros journaliers tout simplement
pas soutenable et cela déstabilise les
équipes de soins avec des effectifs
tournants instables et qui créent de
l'injustice même entre les
professionnels face à ces dérives le
législateur a agi et j'y souscrit je
rappelle d'ailleurs que la loi de 2016
plafonnée de l'intérim à 1170 euros brut
pour une mission de 24 heures ce qui est
loin d'être négligeable cela ne permet
de conserver de l'attractivité pour
l'intérim car il n'est bien entendu pas
question de supprimer tout recours à
l'intérim mais bien de lutter contre
certaines dérives autour de cette la loi
risque qui devait rentrer en vigueur en
octobre 2021 du fait de la crise
sanitaire nous avons dû en décaler cette
mise en œuvre et comme vous l'avez
souligné rentrera en compte à partir du
3 avril vous avez eu aussi la
gentillesse de souligner que nous avons
anticipé cette cette perspective de la
rentrée de cette loi et nous avons
demandé aux ARS un travail établissement
par établissement pour remonter toutes
les problématiques les ARS avaient
jusqu'à lundi soir pour nous faire
remonter toutes les problématiques de
terrain et nous suivons chacune de ces
situations locales avec une très grande
attention nous en rappelons aussi au
secteur privé qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités et jouer aussi le jeu de
l'éthique c'est tous ensemble que nous y
arriverons monsieur sénateur vous le
voyez nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour accompagner les territoires mettre
fin à ses dérives inacceptables et
compter sur notre engagement aux côtés
des ARS pour apporter des réponses
territoire par territoire établissements
par établissement
ministre seul un cap clair précis et
partagé en matière de coopération entre
les établissements de santé publique et
privés médecine de ville ARS
représentant des usagers élus
territoriaux et une dose de
reconnaissance permettra sur la base
d'une participation imposée à tous les
acteurs privés et publics d'assurer une
accessibilité à des soins de qualité 24
heures sur 24 sur tout le territoire
national je vous remercie merci la
parole est à notre collègue Claude Kern
pour le groupe de l'Union santé
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame la ministre des Sports
l'un des refrains refrains de la
communication du comité d'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 et le faire de ces jeux à
succès populaire et accessible à tous le
président du cojob Tony estanguay dont
je salue par ailleurs le travail c'est
lui-même félicité de la liesse suscitée
par la perspective de cet événement
international populaire tout en
rappelant que les recettes de la
billetterie sont indispensables à
l'équilibre des comptes parmi la réalité
pourtant la réalité est tout autre
l'ouverture de la billetterie à l'issue
du tirage au sort s'avère loin du succès
avéré en effet entre la rigidité des
formules proposées notamment le système
de Pâques un choix limité avec beaucoup
d'inconnus et surtout des tarifs jugés
prohibitifs le compte n'y est pas pour
une famille passionnée de sport et qui
rêvait d'assister à des épreuves la
facture écologique grimper à plusieurs
milliers d'euros nous sommes bien loin
des tarifs populaires sur lesquels une
grosse communication a été faite en
creusant un peu nous apprenons par
ailleurs que la moitié des billets à 24
euros ne seront pas mis en vente car
réservé par l'État pour être distribué à
des jeunes et des associations c'est
fort louables mais comprenez que cela a
de quoi créer une réelle frustration de
plus les études comparatives avec les
jeux précédents semblent montrer que les
tarifs de cette édition sont plus élevés
madame la ministre comment expliquer à
des spectateurs passionnés que les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 ne vont avoir
de populaire que le nom que comptez-vous
faire pour que cette géop que nous
attendons depuis 100 ans en France soit
réellement l'événement populaire annoncé
que nous souhaitons tous comment
comptez-vous lutter contre le sentiment
actuel d'exclusion au bénéfice des
valeurs de participation et de
regroupement prônés par l'olympisme
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ligne des forces et des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
Madame le Ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Claude
Kern
vous soulignez à juste titre à
l'importance de cette dimension
d'accessibilité tarifaire de la
billetterie pour les jeux et par là
aussi la nécessité pour notre pays
d'organiser une grande fête populaire à
tous les coins de ce pays alors moi je
voudrais évidemment d'abord dire que ce
principe d'accessibilité tarifaire on y
est tous extraordinairement attaché
rappelez quelques éléments d'abord le
fait que dans les billets qui ont été
mis en vente les 8 millions de billets
qui sont mis en vente par et pour le
grand public par le comité
d'organisation je voudrais vraiment
rappeler que 1 million sont à un prix
d'entrée de 24 euros et ce pour tous les
sports et que 4 millions la moitié sont
à moins de 50 euros évidemment pour que
certains billets soient attractifs il
faut que d'autres soient des tarifs plus
élevés mais le comité d'organisation
éveillé ce qu'elle n'y est pas plus de
10% des billets qui soient plus de 200
la lignée
ces prix sont dans la lignée des
éditions des billets pendant des
éditions précédentes c'est très
important de le rappeler et je voudrais
aussi souligner c'est aussi mon rôle de
ministre des Sports que ce spectacle
réunit les athlètes les plus
exceptionnels du monde à un moment de
grande fête tous les quatre ans pour
obtenir le sésame lui-même le plus
important du monde et que ces jeux ils
doivent être autofinancés ils le sont
sur des fonds privés pour le volet
olympique donc des recettes de
billetterie qui sont importantes mais
moi je veux vraiment rappeler cet
engouement suscité par cette étape de
billetterie les Français se sont
fortement mobilisés 50% des acheteurs
sur 112 nationalités recensées et je ne
veux pas opposer la billetterie
territoriale et la billetterie populaire
qui comme vous l'avez dit viendront
compléter ce volet là en permettant aux
collectivités hautes et demain aux
collectivités terre de jeu de proposer
une billetterie accessible pour leur
public et à l'état d'offrir un certain
nombre de billets à la jeunesse aux
personnes en situation de handicap
ainsi qu'aux bénévoles du mouvement
sportif nous voulons être et nous serons
tous ensemble au rendez-vous de
l'accessibilité tarifaire et d'une
grande fête populaire
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Martin décidrac pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 14
février le Parlement européen votait
l'interdiction de la commercialisation
des véhicules à moteur thermique à
compter de 2035 le 1er mars se vote
devait être entérinaire il a été reporté
au 7 mars c'est-à-dire hier et depuis
reporté à cinédié on cause le blocage de
l'Allemagne de l'Italie de la Pologne et
de la Bulgarie la voiture électrique est
une mobilité décarbonée silencieuse et
confortable bref de l'innovation
technologique mais aujourd'hui Monsieur
le Ministre la voiture électrique c'est
aussi hélas un recyclage insatisfaisant
des batteries dont à peine 46% sont
collectés et d'ailleurs nos collègues
ultramarins pourraient témoigner des
problèmes environnementaux que ces
batteries soulèvent dans leur territoire
la voiture électrique c'est aussi une
menace pour notre souveraineté
industrielle plus de 80% des batteries
sont importées d'Asie
un facteur d'inégalité territoriale
également monsieur le ministre puisque
la dinde juge
bénéfique l'impact carbone de la voiture
électrique pour les trajets en ville et
dans le cas
de vérita dans Monsieur le Ministre à ce
stade la voiture électrique n'a pas
pleinement démontré sa vertu écologique
ni sa pertinence pour la stratégie
industrielle de la France
quelle est la position de la France en
boîte à tel la position de l'Allemagne
de l'Italie de la Pologne et de la
Bulgarie je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
déléguée en charge des transports
monsieur Beaune
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Marta de sidara comme la
rappeler à l'instant à Christophe Béchu
des engagements ont été pris par la
France par l'Allemagne et par l'ensemble
des États européens c'était d'ailleurs
en grande partie sous-présidente
française de l'Union européenne et
toutes les préoccupations que vous
exprimez sont parfaitement fondées mais
aujourd'hui l'alternative est assez
simple refusons-nous ou reportons-nous
cet échéance de 2035 pour la fin de la
vente des véhicules thermiques pas leur
utilisation en général mais leur ventes
ou donnons-nous les moyens de réussir
cette grande ambition écologique et
industrielle par une production en
France et en Europe ces résoluments
cette seconde voie que nous devons
prendre car sinon dans une décennie à
peine nous nous retrouverions ici nous
ou d'autres pour regretter que la France
et l'Europe n'est pas pris le virage que
toutes les grandes puissances
économiques industrielles notamment les
États-Unis notamment la Chine sont en
train de prendre et sur lesquels elles
sont en train d'accélérer nous devons
donc relever ce défi il est absolument
considérable et j'ai hier soir à sa
demande avec mon homologue allemand au
ministre des Transports qui portent
cette préoccupation un peu nouvelle et
comme l'a dit Christophe Béchu
légèrement lié à des considérations de
politique intérieure pour que nous
rappelions ensemble nos engagements pour
relever ce défi pour relever ce défi que
devant nous faire nous devons d'abord
avoir des véhicules accessibles en effet
pour tous les Françaises et tous les
Françaises et tous les Français c'est
absolument essentiel c'est ce que nous
faisons par des aides importantes et il
est vrai que malgré ses aides encore
aujourd'hui souvent le véhicule
électrique est un produit trop cher
parfois un produit de luxe mais nous
devons poursuivre dans cette voie
développer aussi nos bornes électriques
par les aides que nous déployons si nous
renons si nous renonscions maintenant ce
serait un formidable gâchis aussi de
l'argent du contribuable que nous avons
investi et puis c'est un défi industriel
qu'il faut relever nous le faisons avec
Bruno Le Maire en particulier avec
Roland Lescure parce que nous pouvons et
nos constructeurs sont engagés pour
produire en France et en Europe des
véhicules électriques plus abordables
souverain dans les années qui viennent
eux-mêmes nous demandent de tenir ce cap
car sinon ce serait un échec écologique
et un échec industriel pour la France et
pour l'Europe nous devons et nous
pouvons relever ce défi tous ensemble
madame de Sidrac
monsieur le ministre j'observe en fait
que certains de nos partenaires savent
défendre leur intérêts mieux que
d'autres puisque vous avez cité
l'Allemagne mais l'Allemagne justement
fait partie de ces pays qui ne sont pas
d'accord aujourd'hui avec la date de
2035 et au pays de stellantiste et de
Renault je n'ai aucun doute sur la
capacité de notre industrie automobile
de relever ce défi là simplement ce que
je dis c'est que aujourd'hui vous vous
êtes engagé dans un accord de 2035 qui
me semble parfaitement prématuré au
regard des enjeux industriels justement
pour notre pays et aux enjeux
environnementaux qui sont très prégnants
dans nos territoires donc j'espère
monsieur le ministre vous entendrez cet
appel de nos territoires je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Pierre Monnier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et République
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en 2001 la loi
obligatoire trois séances d'éducation à
la sexualité au cours d'une année
scolaire ces séances sont un outil
indispensable au dévoilement des
stéréotypes sexistes à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes à la
compréhension du consentement et à la
prévention contre les pratiques
sexuelles à risque auprès des jeunes en
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes je vous rappelle que le
dernier rapport du Haut Conseil
l'égalité sur l'état des lieux du
sexisme en France a révélé une
recrudescence du sexisme chez les jeunes
hommes 25% d'entre eux pensent qu'il
faut parfois être violent dans une
relation amoureuse contre 11% tous âges
confondus il est plus que jamais
indispensable d'agir et notre premier
levier c'est d'appliquer la loi fin 2020
pendant l'examen du PLF 2021 chalerte
Blanquet monsieur Blanquer car de
nombreuses associations signalent un non
tenue des séances dans certains
établissements le Sénat adopte mon
amendement qui prévoyait d'augmenter le
budget dédié à l'organisation de ces
séances pour que leur mise en œuvre soit
effective Jean-Michel Blanquer
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président évident
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice aujourd'hui en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes au fond là vous posez une
question sur l'éducation à la sexualité
qui concerne toutes et tous filles comme
garçon vous l'avez dit c'est une mission
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
qui a été mise en place par la loi du 4
juillet 2001 et depuis effectivement
chaque année trois séances d'éducation à
la sexualité adaptée à leurs âges
doivent pouvoir être dispensés aux
élèves le ministre d'éducation nationale
que j'excuse aujourd'hui dès son arrivée
à lancer une enquête de manière à voir
la réalité de ces cours et de leur
dispensation dans l'ensemble des
territoires
si il a également réalisé deux
circulaires aux inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale et au chef
d'établissement pour que ces cours
soient effectivement dispensés il
s'avère qu'effectivement des progrès
doivent pouvoir être fait en la matière
c'est tout le sens de du plan
interministériel lancé par madame la
Première ministre qui notamment dans son
axe 4 à prévoit un renforcement de
l'éducation à la sexualité qui vient
accompagner la culture
aux enjeux c'est tout le sens également
de ce qui est lancé dans ce plan au
travers d'une enquête annuelle de la de
la réalité des actions mises en oeuvre
ainsi qu'un plan de formation du
personnel de l'éducation nationale vous
évoquez les trois associations qui
attaquent l'État pour la non mise en
oeuvre de cette loi de 2001 je m'en
étonne permettez-moi car ce sont des
actions qui interviennent dans nos
établissements qui travaillent avec nous
et que pour certaines nous finançons
elles ont bien sûr le droit de ce
recours mais je tiens à dire que nous
n'avons pas attendu pour nous engager
sur le sujet c'est une grande cause
portée par le Président de la République
et un plan à nouveau lancé pour 2027 par
madame la Première ministre bien la
parole est à notre collègue Guillaume
chevrolier pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre les
importants épisode de sécheresse de
l'été dernier n'était finalement que les
prémices d'une pénurie qui s'installe
désormais dans la durée à ce jour nous
avons deux mois de retard sur la
recharge des nappes phréatiques une
sécheresse hivernale inédite l'accès à
l'eau potable que l'on croyait garantir
à tous nos concitoyens est aujourd'hui
menacé d'autant plus que nous constatons
la réduction des débits des cours d'eau
qui entraîne une concentration des
micropollants et pose un vrai problème
sanitaire pour la potabilité de l'eau
au-delà de nos concitoyens la tension
sur l'eau a bien entendu un impact sur
le fonctionnement de nos entreprises de
notre agriculture les cultures l'élevage
mais aussi nos centrales nucléaires le
Sénat a mené un certain nombre de
travaux autour de cette problématique en
présentant plusieurs pistes pour
améliorer notre gestion de l'eau que ce
soit la conciliation des usages la
sensibilisation du grand public à la
sobriété les retenus d'eau ou la
nécessaire modernisation de l'irrigation
pour nos agriculteurs les propositions
ne manquent pas mais ils ont besoin de
financement monsieur le ministre dans ce
contexte qui est préoccupe tous
plusieurs départements ont déjà été
placés en situation d'alerte sécheresse
mais il est évident que le temps n'est
plus à la réaction mais à l'anticipation
indispensable et à l'adaptation de notre
pays au changement climatique monsieur
le ministre ma question est simple
pouvez-vous nous exposer de façon très
concrète votre politique
d'anticipation sur l'eau à défaut
d'avoir anticipé la crise de l'énergie
le gouvernement prendra-t-il toutes les
mesures nécessaires afin de faire face à
la crise de l'eau
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transition écologique
de la cohésion du territoire monsieur
Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Guillaume Chevrollier
c'est plus de 700 communes privées d'eau
potable l'été dernier et 1260 cours
d'eau qui ont été en rupture
d'écoulement contenu de l'épisode de
sécheresse qu'on a connu et à la fin de
l'été un niveau des nappes
particulièrement bas et la période de
recharge jusqu'à ce début de semaine non
seulement on n'a pas permis de recharger
c'est nappes mais compte tenu du mois de
février que nous avons connu la même
aggraver et donc le chiffre que vous
donnez de ces deux mois de retard en
moyenne sur les nappes phréatiques est
une réalité depuis 24 heures nous avons
des épisodes de pluie abondants qui
malheureusement de concerneront pas le
pourtour méditerranéen et le couloir
rodanien on peut penser et espérer que
sur une large partie nord du pays on
devrait avoir des pluies qui permettront
au niveau de recharge mais quand on dit
de moins de retard c'est pas de moindre
retard par rapport à la moyenne c'est
deux mois de retard par rapport à la
situation d'avant l'été 2022 ce qui
explique la préoccupation qu'elle a
notre
l'anticipation l'adaptation en matière
de changement climatique ce que nous
disent des experts c'est qu'on pourrait
avoir entre 10 et 40% de volume de pluie
en moins et avec parfois des épisodes
trop plus vieux pour permettre une
recharge des nappes dans de bonnes
conditions parce que si la pluie est
trop forte en particulier si on se
préoccupe pas de lutter contre
l'artificialisation en faisant en sorte
de pouvoir permettre la recharger nappe
si on se préoccupe pas de la
perméabilité des sols on aggra une
partie de ce de cette situation à très
court terme réunion d'un comité
anticipation sécheresse des 23 février
réunion des préfets de bassin de 27
réunions de tous les préfets lundi
dernier pour dire partout prenez dès
maintenant des mesures qu'on prend
habituellement plus tard si la situation
justifie la suite dans quelques jours le
plan o plus de 50 mesures nous nous
sommes inspirés des travaux du Sénat
comme tout était écrit j'ai pas conduit
des auditions avec mes collègues pour
entendre les uns et les autres mais on a
lu avec beaucoup d'attention les
rapports sur les mesures qui étaient
préconisées et vous retrouverez une
partie de votre pâte ou de vos enquêtes
dans ce qui sera présenté qui traitera
de quantité de qualité et de gouvernance
l'enjeu il est devant nous il nécessite
une union sacrée parce que vous l'avez
dit l'eau c'est la vie et l'eau c'est
nécessaire pour l'agriculture pour
l'industrie et bien sûr pour nos
concitoyens monsieur chevrolier oui
merci monsieur le ministre de vous
inspirer des travaux du Sénat
effectivement dans cette crise de l'eau
le soutien financier au collectivités
locales est indispensable elles ont la
connaissance et la maîtrise du terrain
et seront trouvées les solutions les
plus adaptées pour une eau comme vous
l'avez dit en quantité et en qualité et
avec les éventuels mesures de
restriction le gouvernement doit
informer de façon transparente j'ose
dire limpide afin de permettre
l'acceptibilité des contraintes
la parole
est à notre collègue Michel cadavet pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues la France est
un grand pays maritime et nous tenons à
ce qu'il le demeure mais c'est vrai que
la filière a lutter connaît de
nombreuses difficultés de nombreux
inquiétudes il y a notamment le pays qui
va sortir
90 navires de la flotte française il y a
aussi les inquiétudes liées au carburant
puisque l'équilibre économique de
nombreux armements et mis en inquiétude
donc il convient de bien porter des
solutions là aussi et puis les pêcheurs
en ont marre en quelque sorte d'être
culpabilisé par les prises d'accessoires
de dauphins la population de dauphins
notamment à largement augmenté dans le
seau Atlantique et à chaque fois qu'il y
en a sur le littoral on montre du doigt
les pêcheurs mais la principale source
d'inquiétude mais dans ces messieurs
c'est notamment le projet d'interdiction
du chalutage qui a été proposé par la
Commission européenne voilà quelques
jours et ce dans les aires protégées
l'inquiétude est forte parce que
imagine-t-on demain qu'on ne puisse plus
aller pêcher les coquilles Saint-Jacques
en baisse Saint-Brieuc imagine-t-on
demain qu'on ne puisse plus non plus
manger les langoustines ou la lotte au
large de déglénant imagine-toi encore
qu'on ne puisse plus
ment les huîtres de pleine mer tout
simplement parce qu'on ne pourra pas les
récupérer bien non donc je souhaite
connaître la position du gouvernement à
l'égard de cette proposition de la
Commission européenne et de manière plus
générale quelles sont les propositions
qui soient faites pour accompagner la
filière pêche dans les difficultés
aujourd'hui pour vous répondre la parole
est co secrétaire des télécharge de la
mer Monsieur Hervé Berville monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Michel cannett
d'abord je vous remercie de votre
mobilisation dans un magnifique
territoire qui est le Finistère pour le
maintien et le développement de la
filière pêche française vous l'avez dit
cette proposition de la Commission
européenne d'interdire tout engin de
fond dans les aires marines protégées a
été évoqué il a quelques semaines à
Bruxelles je le dis très clairement ça a
été rappelé par la première ministre au
salon de l'agriculture par le Président
de la République au salon de
l'agriculture et par moi-même il y a de
cela deux semaines au calvados la France
le gouvernement est totalement opposé à
cette communication et à la mise en
oeuvre de l'interdiction des engins de
fond dans les aires marines protégées
totalement clairement et fermement pour
moi trois raisons la première c'est que
ça ne reconnaît absolument pas et ça
méconnait même les efforts fait depuis
des années par les pêcheurs et donc nous
voyons vous l'avez évoqué je le connais
bien et je sais l'attachement notamment
aussi du sénateur Alain cadet sur ce
sujet que les pêcheurs avec les efforts
qu'ils ont fournis depuis des années ont
permis la reconstitution de nombreux
stocks dont les stocks de coquilles
Saint-Jacques deuxièmement une prime en
mauvaise élève parce que tous les pays
qui du coup ont mis des aires marines
protégées se retrouvent désormais
sanctionnés et obligé et bien
d'interdire ces engins de fond et puis
c'est une folie pour la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays nous dépendons
déjà à plus de 80 % un très bon texte du
sénateur Cadec avait évoqué ce sujet là
nous dépendons à 80 % des importations
pour les produits de la pêche et nous
allons donc continuer à augmenter cette
part d'importation donc nous disons très
clairement il faut arrêter d'opposer le
développement de la filière halieutique
avec la question la protection la
biodiversité de la marine nous pouvons
emmener les deux de front et nous
l'avons démontré en France depuis des
années et la priorité du gouvernement
elle est de faire en sorte qu'on
continue à avoir des capacités de
production d'entraîner toute la filière
sur la décarbonation et la réduction aux
énergies fossiles et nous l'avons
démontré puisque nous soutenons cette
filière avec par quatre fois la
prolongation des aides carburants et
également par le soutien partout sur nos
territoires à cette belle filière
Monsieur calavet Merci monsieur le
ministre de cet engagement fort du
gouvernement les marins-pêcheurs
l'attendent et effectivement il convient
d'être particulièrement actif parce que
demain c'est une question de
souveraineté et effectivement le je sais
que le sénateur à lacadec mais c'est
plutôt un pêcheur normaux et aussi
attaché à tout cela en tout cas nous
sommes nous mobilisés et merci de votre
engagement merci nous avons terminé
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement aura lieu le mercredi 15
mars à 15h je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour la suite
de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement
nous sommes à 11 minutes maintenant de
la reprise des débats ici à la haute
assemblée sur la réforme des retraites
et pour en parler j'accueille Patrick
canner bonjour bonjour président du
groupe socialiste ici au Sénat vous avez
interrogé cet après-midi la première
ministre sur cette réforme des retraites
sur les outils réglementaires qui ont
été utilisés par la droite sénatoriale à
cette nuit pour accélérer les débats
également sur la mobilisation très forte
hier dans la rue on a senti une première
ministre qui reste droit dans ses bottes
sur la réforme des retraites tel quel
oui effectivement
lis ces fiches sans défaillir et il n'a
pas répondu aux questions que je lui ai
posé je lui ai posé la question est-ce
que par exemple monsieur le Président de
la République est d'accord pour recevoir
l'internical qui le demande pas de
réponse et encore moi bien sûr sur
l'idée d'une d'un retrait de la réforme
dont ne veulent pas les français donc
voilà c'est je dirais un exercice
convenu entre le patron d'un groupe
parlementaire de position et la première
ministre c'est dommage parce que les
Français je pense se mériteraient plus
d'explications sur le fond alors cette
nuit il y a eu de fortes tensions entre
la droite et la gauche sénatoriale les
sénateurs de gauche ont d'ailleurs
claqué la porte de l'hémicycle après une
bataille d'outils réglementaires pour
peser sur le rythme des débats dans
quels états d'esprit vous êtes avec
avant cette reprise de la science alors
que il y a un nouvel outil qui va être
utilisé par la droite l'article 42 pour
limiter le temps de parole de chaque
groupe sur cette réforme de retraite les
droites au Sénat qu'elles soient
l'iséennes
macroniste ou LR ou centriste veulent
avoir un texte veulent ce texte ils
veulent pénaliser les 18 millions de
Français qui seront les premières
victimes du report de l'âge légal pour
ce faire ils vont utiliser une
artillerie lourde permettez-moi
l'expression
d'abord des articles modificatifs enfin
des amendements modificatifs qui
passeront en priorité pour faire tomber
les nôtres exemplaires c'était le cas
sur l'article 7 un amendement a fait
tomber 1100 amendements portés par la
gauche on va utiliser l'article 38 pour
limiter le temps de parole et même chose
avec l'article 42 sans rentrer dans les
détails c'est la volonté finalement de
considérer que l'opposition n'a pas son
mot à dire en tout cas elle peut dire un
mot mais pas trop long et vous en face
vous continuerez à déposer des centaines
des milliers d'amendements pour ralentir
les débats nous utiliserons les moyens
qui sont à notre disposition et
effectivement les sous amendements sont
un outil qui existe et nous verrons bien
comment la commission des affaires
sociales les recevra donc la bataille va
continuer ce soir la bataille la guerre
était déclenchée hier soir et nous bien
nous allons rentrer dans une logique de
résistance merci beaucoup Patrick canard
dans quelques instants on accueillera
votre homologue président du groupe LR
ici au Sénat Bruno otao merci
merci merci beaucoup Alexandre pour
cette réaction autre réaction
effectivement celle de Bruno Retailleau
qui s'installe le patron des sénateurs
LR bonjour Bruno Retailleau dans quel
état d'esprit êtes-vous à 10 minutes de
la reprise des débats ici au Sénat sur
la réforme des retraites est-ce que vous
allez continuer à utiliser tous les
outils du règlement pour accélérer ces
débats bien sûr on a à faire à une
obstruction de la gauche c'est simple il
y a une minorité qui veulent bloquer la
majorité ça ça n'est pas la démocratie
parlementaire je veux simplement
rappeler que faire de l'obstruction
c'est effacer le Parlement c'est comme
si le Parlement se faisait arrêt araray
une sorte de d'article 49-3 à l'envers
je pense que choisir de ne pas voter
c'est choisir de ne pas peser et moi je
préoccupe un petit peu de notre
institution du texte parce que il y a
l'article 7 mais il y a d'autres
articles qui sont très importants on
veut parler du handicap on veut parler
de l'usure professionnelle de
l'invalidité des petites retraites des
femmes et et la gauche tout bloque et ça
c'est anti démocratique donc vous
craignez que la gauche ne réussisse
finalement à empêcher le vote final je
crée un ce que je crains c'est que et je
le dis à mes collègues de gauche nous
assistons à une mélenchonisation de la
gauche sénatoriale et notamment sous la
fait et la pointe du groupe du petit
groupe écologie d'une petite minorité au
Sénat il y a une maison Monsieur
Mélenchon d'ailleurs a fait récemment un
tweet et ça c'est très préoccupant parce
que si on importe les mauvaises
habitudes de l'Assemblée nationale au
Sénat je pense que c'est le
parlementarisme qui va en prendre un
coup mais justement ce qu'a dit ce matin
la présidente du groupe communiste Elian
assassin dans sa conférence de presse
commune avec les autres présidents de
groupe c'est que je cite Gérard Larcher
c'était assis sur le droit d'amendement
qui est fondamental du parlementarisme
mais c'est absolument faux on a eu des
centaines des milliers d'amendements on
a assisté avec beaucoup de patience
pendant cinq jours et cinq nuits à des
amendements répét avec des explications
de vote répétitif etc l'objectif c'était
pas de faire progresser le débat c'était
de le bloquer c'est d'être faire en
sorte que on ne parvienne pas au vote et
c'est ça qui n'est pas normal et c'est
ça qui est une manœuvre
anti-démocratique et on ouvre les portes
à l'anti parlementarisme parce que les
Français vont constater que le Parlement
finalement discute mais à quoi sert-il
si votre vote pas vous allez dégainer de
nouveaux outils du règlement on parle de
l'article 42 du Règlement du Sénat qui
va à limiter le temps de parole des
groupes politiques bien sûr on a on a un
règlement mais ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on revienne à la raison et que une
minorité une minorité ne bloque pas le
travail d'une majorité c'est ça la
démocratie
si il y a plus de fonctionnement
démocratique et bien il y a plus du tout
de règles il y a plus du tout cette
canalisation et si c'est la rue qui fait
ici au Sénat finalement la loi il y a
plus du tout non plus de démocratie
parlementaire merci pour nos Retailleau
on suivra avec attention la reprise de
ces débats sur la réforme des retraites
au Sénat à 16h30 merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre et on le sent il va y avoir du
débat dans l'hémicycle sur la réforme
des retraites mais vous allez également
auparavant accueillir Clément Baule le
ministre des Transports pour parler des
blocages et de la journée de
mobilisation d'hier bonjour Clément
bonne alors après cette journée de
mobilisation hier à des manifestations
record également des grèves qu'elle
analyse faites-vous de la situation dans
les transports dans les prochains jours
est-ce que les grèves vont persister et
mettre un petit peu plus les transports
à l'arrêt il y a encore des grèves dans
les transports publics on le voit
malheureusement ce mercredi il y a une
légère amélioration pas toujours
également perceptible dans la vie
quotidienne j'en suis parfaitement
conscient ça ira mieux demain et
vendredi progressivement on donnera
ensuite des prévisions qui sont trop tôt
pour formuler aujourd'hui pour ce
week-end j'espère que la situation
s'améliorera de manière très très nette
d'ici la fin de la semaine mais en tout
cas jeudi vendredi les choses à la RATP
de manière nette elle a SNCF également
dans une moindre mesure vont s'améliorer
et sont en train de s'améliorer mais je
l'ai dit aussi il y aura des
perturbations qui persisteront quand
même vous dites ça va aller mieux dans
les prochains jours et pourtant quand on
entend par exemple les syndicats de
cheminots ils disent on est parti pour
une grève qui va durer ça peut se
prolonger la semaine prochaine dans les
prochaines semaines et je ne le sais pas
et je veux pas être ni fataliste ni
pessimiste on donnera les choses parce
qu'on parle de la vie quotidienne des
gens à chaque fois qu'elles seront
claires précises je préfère être honnête
et transparent à chaque étape parce que
beaucoup d'usagers du service public ont
besoin de savoir ce qui est clair c'est
qu'on sera pas dans un service normal
sur l'ensemble des transports publics
jeudi et vendredi ce qui est clair aussi
c'est qu'il y a néanmoins une
amélioration et je prends un exemple
très concret pour la rat pour la journée
de jeudi le service de bus par exemple
ou le tramway sera entièrement assuré
les perturbations seront plutôt dans le
métro par exemple que faire pour ces
Français qui voient leur avion leur
train annulés qui sont obligés de payer
des hôtels pour rester sur place à
l'endroit de leur déplacement eux ils
sont pénalisés bien sûr je le sais bien
une grève malheureusement ça a des
impacts c'est évidemment on fait tout
pour les minimiser pour que ça dure le
moins longtemps possible et quand il y
en a aussi pour les anticiper je sais
que ça ne remet pas un train ou un avion
sur les rails ou dans les airs mais ça
permet à ceux qui le peuvent ceux qui le
peuvent de s'organiser au mieux
éventuellement de reporter ou de décaler
un déplacement je sais aussi que pour
beaucoup de Français les transports
publics sont une nécessité et donc on
fait tout pour que cette galère dure le
moins longtemps possible aussi par le
dialogue et par la discussion car moi
j'y crois toujours et je le fais avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
des entreprises publiques alors dans ce
débat au Sénat sur la réforme des
retraites Bruno Retailleau le patron du
groupe les républicains souhaite une
accélération de la suppression
un régime spéciaux vous dites ça va
mettre de l'huile sur le feu c'est une
mauvaise idée je dis on a un équilibre
celui du gouvernement est défendu dans
le texte depuis le départ d'ailleurs ici
même au Sénat l'article 1er sur les
régimes spéciaux a été voté sans changer
cet équilibre qui est très simple c'est
qu'on ferme les régimes spéciaux pour
l'avenir et on garde les conditions
existantes pour ceux qui avaient un
régime spécial dans les années précédent
je pense que c'est juste et équilibré je
rappelle aussi que la fermeture des
régimes spéciaux personne ne l'avait
fait complètement nous le faisons dans
cette réforme gardons cet équilibre il
demande déjà un effort important j'en
suis le garant dans le secteur des
transports et les quitter et je crois
assurer par cet équilibre là donc vous
l'aurez compris je souhaite qu'on le
préserve et qu'on n'avait pas plus loin
et on verra dans les prochains jours le
débat qui aura lieu normalement au Sénat
sur cette accélération ou non de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux merci
beaucoup Clément bonne d'être venu au
micro de public c'est NON MERCI BEAUCOUP
Alexandre pour toutes ces réactions on
va rejoindre Quentin dans l'hémicycle
car Quentin on parle de la réforme des
retraites et bien sûr il en a été
question lors de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement
[Musique]
car je le rappelle c'est bien dans la
concertation et le dialogue que ce texte
a été construit
et vous l'avez dit Quentin les sénateurs
viennent de commencer l'examen de
l'article 7 article névralgique de ce
projet de loi et il y a eu une soirée
très mouvementée une nuit très de
mouvement théière
jusqu'à 3h30 du matin nous étions en
direct pour tout vivre effectivement
l'examen de l'article 7 il a commencé
hier vers 19h en séance mais ça c'est
véritablement agité autour de une heure
et demie du matin point de départ le
moment où Bruno retaille au chef de fil
des LR du Sénat enclenche l'article 38
du Règlement du Sénat un article et qui
vient contraindre le nombre de prises de
parole sur chacun de manque là à ce
moment-là la gauche dénonce
l'utilisation de cet article 38 dit que
c'est un scandale qu'il y a un
bayonnement de l'opposition sénatoriale
et dans le même temps on voit le
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse René
Paul Savary qui annonce une suspension
de séance pour la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales hier
soir une réunion qui dure quelques
minutes et où l'on apprend que ce dépose
une nouvelle version de l'article 7 sur
les 64 ans qu'est-ce que ça signifie à
ce moment-là dans l'hémicycle ça
signifie et il est à peu près 1h30 2h du
matin ça signifie que 1000 amendements
de la gauche sénatoriale tombe ne
peuvent plus être examinés c'est donc un
coup dur pour la gauche du matériel qui
vous laisse opposer au texte mais que la
droite assume complètement vous l'en
répondre à l'obstruction à un quel
estime de l'obstruction de la part de la
gauche sauf que et bien ça ne s'arrête
pas là on voit la soirée qui continue de
nouvelles suspensions et la gauche
notorielle qui avait préparé des
milliers de sous amendements à cet
amendement ça varie pour également
pouvoir reprendre la parole dans ce qui
se joue à ce moment-là on assiste alors
à une nouvelle suspension de séance de
45 minutes et au retour d'une réunion de
la commission des affaires sociales on
apprend que c'est sous amendements de la
gauche ont tous été jugés ils recevable
par le Sénat et la gauche qui à ce
moment là décide de quitter l'hémicycle
dénonce un nouveau
et décide de ne plus siéger dans la
suite des débats et donc c'est sur ce
moment là que c'est son suspendus les
débats à 3h30 du matin hier et il reste
maintenant à peu près 75 amendements qui
restent à examiner sur cet article 7 sur
les 64 ans puisque cet article n'a
toujours pas été fini d'être examiné il
y aura donc peut-être un vote
aujourd'hui dans les prochaines heures
de la soirée mais donc il reste des
amendements à examiner de tout bord
confondu ce sont 75 amendements qui ont
été retenus à la fois des bandes DLR des
bancs même des communistes donc on va
voir si ce débat un peu reprendre
sereinement ou si la gauche dénonce
toujours les conditions de cinéma
surtout que dernière information Tam le
la majorité de la droite et du centre a
décidé d'utiliser un autre article du
règlement ça a été décidé ce matin en
conférence des présidents l'article 42
qui va limiter les prises de parole au
prorata de l'importance des groupes
politiques dans l'hémicycle Tam merci
merci beaucoup
Valentin et oui on le voit la droite et
la majorité sénatoriale elle sort toutes
les armes pour raccourcir le débat on va
rejoindre Alexandre pousse-arts celle
des conférences qui se trouvent avec
Pierre-Antoine Lévy et oui
Pierre-Antoine Lévy on est à quelques
secondes la reprise des débats ici au
Sénat sur la réforme de retraite donc
quel état d'esprit sont les sénateurs
centrist c'est ce que vous dites oui il
faut accélérer les débats quitte à
utiliser des outils du règlement pour
bâillonner la gauche alors je trouve que
vous allez dur en disant qu'on Bayonne
on les a écouté
patient on a écouté des milliers
d'interventions depuis jeudi dernier
quand même et sur l'article 7 on a
écouté 54 prises de parole plus 70
articles identiques qui ont été
présentés intégralement par tous les
sénateurs socialistes écologistes et
communistes donc on a bayonné personne
et un moment donné il faut qu'on
accélère parce que qu'est-ce
qu'attendait français également ils ont
manifesté mais ils attendent aussi que
le Sénat vaut un texte or il reste
encore il reste encore 2300 amendements
on en a étudié 1500 et aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on passe maintenant à la vitesse
supérieure et les présidents retaillaux
au président de Marseille et le
président expliquer qu'il y avait des
articles de disposition et si la gauche
continue à faire de l'obstruction les
mettra en application donc la gauche
c'était préparée puisque quand même 3000
amendements de sous-amendement sortir
une demi-heure ou doutez bien quand même
que ils étaient préparés ils avaient
déjà préparé leurs armes donc bien sûr
qu'il faut continuer il faut qu'on
examine les textes parce que au-delà
d'article 7 il y a des avancées très
notable pour les petites retraites pour
les femmes notamment avec la surcotte et
il faut qu'on les examine alors
justement on va arriver à la fin de
l'examen de cet article 7 il reste quand
même des amendements à discuter sur
cette article 7 qui reporte l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans est-ce
qu'il faut le voter tel quel cet article
7 ou on peut encore l'améliorer alors
cet article 7 on peut l'améliorer vous
allez noter que ce qui me concerne je me
suis abstenu sur la suppression
d'article 7 tout simplement parce que ce
qui me concerne je pensais qu'il fallait
aller plus loin sur la pénibilité mais
il faut qu'on nous votion une réforme
qui servait quelque chose et qui donne
les moyens financiers surtout de dans
les années 2030 d'ici 2030 de régler une
partie du déficit même si on sait il
reviendra dans quelques années donc en
ce qui me concerne je me suis abstenu je
vais m'abstiendrai certainement sur
l'article 7 ce qui veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas voter la réforme voilà mais il
faut accélérer parce qu'il y a encore
une fois des des avancées notables et
notamment sur les petites pensions
puisque nous avons nous pensons aux
petites retraites et si on veut avoir
une chance de pouvoir les augmenter au
mois de septembre comme ça a été évoqué
il faut qu'on accélère le texte donc cet
article 7 c'est l'article symbole de la
gauche mais il y avait article je
rappelle dans cette loi il faut qu'on
avance et qu'on vote le texte si on peut
juste pour finir sur cette article 7
vous êtes absolu sur sa suppression car
vous êtes mal à l'aise quand vous
entendez le mécontentement peut-être
dans votre circonscription j'écoute pas
dans ma circonscription j'écoute la
France aujourd'hui effectivement on ne
peut pas ignorer ce qui se dit dans la
rue mais ce qu'il faut que les gens
sachent aussi c'est que quand on est
parlementaire on doit être responsable
et voter des lois qui servent à quelque
chose aujourd'hui nous votons une loi
nous sommes là pour examiner nos lois
qui est là pour sauver notre régime de
retraite Paris partition il y a deux
chocs de vous avez deux affrontements un
affrontement de la gauche contre la
droite nous pour nous notre nos
marqueurs centrist et nous les avons
fait entendre dans le cadre de la
commission mais aujourd'hui il faut
écouter la rue bien évidemment mais on
peut pas non plus faire des lois en
fonction de la rue on est là aussi pour
adapter et surtout écouter ce qui se dit
mais il faut que les gens sachent quand
même que cette retraite cette réforme
des retraites elle doit être faite elle
doit on doit la voter et on doit sauver
notre régime de retraite tout simplement
parce que on peut pas dire aux gens dans
10 ans ou dans 15 ans on va où baisser
vos pensions parce qu'on n'a pas été
responsable pour voter la réforme merci
beaucoup Pierre Antoine Lévy pour votre
réaction votre intervention à quelques
secondes de la reprise de ces débats sur
la réforme des retraites ici au Sénat on
va retourner en tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat ou Quentin vous allez suivre ce
soir et cette nuit c'est débat sur la
forme des retraites voilà tout à fait
Alex alors que la séance vient de
reprendre à l'instant c'est
effectivement un rappel au règlement de
Pierre Laurent qui est en cours on
retourne dans l'hémicycle en direct
cette nuit pour accélérer la clôture
autoritaire des débats sur l'article 7
et sur le projet de loi retraite la
commission des affaires sociales a
invoqué l'article 44 bis du règlement
pour déclarer irrecevable plusieurs
centaines de sous amendements qui ont
été déposés après la réécriture de
l'article 7 qui sont devenus subitement
hirsovables alors que les amendements
qu'il reproduisaient avec eux étaient
déclarés recevables par la même
commission la présidente de roche sur la
figure au compte-rendu a d'ailleurs
reconnu qu'il s'agissait des mêmes
amendements mais le vice-président
karucci nous a en quelque sorte livré
l'explication de texte
à partir du moment où l'article
réécrit était devenu un amendement cela
rendait soi-disant impossible de le
sous-amender en le on contestant le sens
effectivement le règlement 40 bis rend
impossible au dépôt d'un sous amendement
qui soit contraire à l'amendement auquel
il s'applique mais achète en
l'occurrence un détournement de sens du
règlement car si nous acceptons cette
interprétation il suffit alors de
transformer un article entier et ça a
été le cas cette nuit on en abondement
on le réécrivant pour le rendre
inabondable c'est-à-dire l'article qui
est lui-même
constitutionnellement amandables et
contestable devient par le jeu d'une
réécriture en amendement un article
inammondable c'est donc une atteinte de
fait à la capacité et au droit
constitutionnel d'amendements des
parlementaires
il faut donc être extrêmement vigilant
mes chers collègues vers sur ce
précédent car c'est un précédent qui a
été créé et qui ouvre la porte à toutes
les manipulations contre le droit
d'amendement et jeudi au républicains
assumer le vote du la loi
madame Brunin
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mon rappel
au règlement se fonde sur l'article 44
de la Constitution les membres du
Parlement et le gouvernement ont le
droit d'amendement cette nuit en effet
des sous amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables sans même avoir été examiné
en commission de la veuve même de sa
présidence nombre des notes portaient
sur des précisions techniques
manifestement parfaitement recevable ce
droit inaliénable d'amendement a été
utilisé par la commission pour
reformuler l'article 7 dans une version
quasi identique au texte originel dans
le seul but de faire disparaître les
amendements des groupes de gauche qui
relaient ici les préoccupations de nos
concitoyens mobilisés très massivement
encore hier ces amendements portés par
exemple sur l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ en retraite ces sujets que
vous nous disiez vouloir débattre que
vraiment entendu ici sur l'examen de ce
texte à l'Assemblée nationale mais ce
qui se passe ici même au Sénat et
l'autre face d'une même pièce empêcher
le travail parlementaire sur ce texte et
cela non non pas le Sénat où est passé
la sagesse que vous convoquez
régulièrement
où est la rigueur légendaire du Sénat
disparu dans de basses manœuvres qui
n'effaceront pas nous vous le disons mes
chers collègues la détermination du
peuple français a rejeté cette réforme
et cette très très mauvaise réforme
merci chers collègues monsieur gay
pour un rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article
je m'exprime devant vous avec solennité
mes chers collègues et une colère froide
nos débats sont très suivis à
l'extérieur beaucoup nous ont dit qu'il
comptait sur nous tout et tous pour
échanger avoir un débat de fond et pour
notre paragua gauche nous y opposer pour
les faire échec car nous sommes dans
l'opposition depuis jeudi nous pensons
que nous faisons la politique en ayant
un débat argumenté précisé documenté ce
qui est bien le rôle du Parlement tant
que nous sommes pas passés à la Sixième
République et changer de constitution
chaque parlementaire a le droit de
déposer un amendement et de le défendre
même si la droite accusait la gauche
d'une obstruction cordiale et qu'en
réponse nous vous renvoyons celle d'une
obstruction
silencieuse nous avons aussi dans le
débat
celui que nous avons eu dimanche projet
comme projet répartition contre
capitalisation a été utile je le pense
qui peut dire ici que nous avons perdu
du temps c'est pour ça que hier nous
avons été très sûrs
38 reste régnant la parole puis la
réécriture de l'article 7 rendant
innamandable cet article et enfin
déclarant nos amendements devenus sous
amendements
anticonstitutionnel pour question
d'égalité alors qu'une demi-heure avant
il ne l'était pas sans pourvoir nous
l'expliquer si on y rajoute les
décisions pris ce matin avec de
nouvelles dispositions pour réduire une
nouvelle fois le temps de parole c'est
un coup de force coup de force certes
permis par le règlement mais le
règlement n'est que là pour organiser
notre vie commune lorsqu'on l'utilise
pour régler une question politique c'est
que nous sommes au bord d'une crise
démocratique en fait l'utilisation de
toutes ces règles prouve votre fébrilité
et montrent que vous avez besoin
d'autoritarisme pour établir votre
autorité politique vous avez perdu et
vous le savez vous êtes minoritaire
alors que chacun sera sur ici que celles
et ceux qui luttent dehors nous restons
utile et déterminés ici comme samedi
prochain